and some of the stuff is just kind of
trying to convince people of false cures
if some is really ridiculous I mean the
most ridiculous example I think that
I've seen is one saying that if you
think you have coronavirus you can drink
bleach and that will cure you
which obviously it will not and and not
only will it not but that's that's
obviously extremely dangerous and
something that no one should be doing so
we want to make sure that we take that
kind of misinformation down anything
that's going to put people an imminent
risk of harm and we work with the w-h-o
it's a trusted organization that
basically can give us a list of these
debunked claims so we can operationalize
that and go out and find them
and try to take that down you must have
an unstoppable mindset in a new economy
like this and make no mistake about it
guys and gals we are in a new economy
it's not just a virus that you have to
worry about it is the repercussions of
the closures of business the
unemployment that's gonna take place the
new way the business is going to get
done like look if you're in the fitness
industry like we are we saw this coming
the moment China had it and we saw
though closures happening and I
immediately went to alright man you keep
telling yourself you were born for
winter you are built for winter you are
made for winter well what would you do
if this virus came to the United States
and we went with the mindset of we're
gonna pivot and go into online coaching
and so we created a killer online
coaching program follow along workout
videos for Fit Body Boot Camp loners
worldwide because we saw that there was
a potential of closures happening and so
with that said since we saw the closures
and the potential of Fit Body Boot camps
and gyms in general happening and for an
extended period of time by the way if
you think this is only gonna be for two
weeks and then you're back to normal you
have got another thing coming this is
not going to just be for two weeks it
may not be for four weeks it may be
longer right now if I were you I would
adopt the mindset that this is the new
economy until further notice like adopt
a mindset this is new economy until
further notice and things may not get to
normal because this is the
and if you think in that unstoppable way
right now you're not going to be
surprised and let be let down when
whether it's Trump or your local
governor or mayor says hey look we still
have to be on lockdown and there's
limits to what businesses will be open
or what those businesses can do etc I
think that are not missing yet we
couldn't really say everything's gonna
happen how far does this shake at it
could get a lot worse it really could or
it could actually not be quite as bad in
terms of that I think this reason that
this that the WHL in the World Health
Organization declared it officially uh
pandemic is because they want people to
take this seriously they want people to
understand that the stakes are really
really high because frankly one thing
that I think China has proven assuming
that what they're saying is true is that
they're radical and you know sometimes
draconian measures they took and
necessary measures they took to stop the
spread of this worked they were actually
slowed down the transmission it was out
of control and move on and they
literally cordon it off they closed it
down their quarantine the whole the
whole you know your geographic area and
now they're ahead of the virus this does
not mean that people will not still get
it in China but they're pulling ahead
now versus underwater with you know you
know you know it's exponentially
increasing number of new cases every
single day so I think that the w-h-o
understands that it's so critical right
now that we do take this seriously in
terms of social distancing and slowing
the transmission as much as possible so
the healthcare systems can slowly or you
know as quickly as possible
adapt to this new stress get the
resources in place as quickly as
possible including testing kits my
daughters
okay my daughter might know I might like
my daughter's in New York I'm worried
about her I'm worried about my kids here
okay and you know it's hard to get
testing kids am I worried about the
corner the corona
I mean I'm concerned for sure I know
that I'm not gonna be outside you know
so yeah I mean I don't think I'm gonna
get it but you know what I think I could
get it if I'm reckless you know I mean
what I'm not gonna be reckless you know
the funny thing is for me anything that
could happen will happen so you know
becoming you know making rockefeller and
being this successful is almost like
lotto right it doesn't happen if so many
people but what comes with that is that
means everything that happens or that
doesn't usually happen to people will
happen a good aunt Abed
I can almost my girl in a plane crash
you know I'm saying it ain't normal
so we're not when I hear that something
could happen I'm not gonna be like oh
won't happen to me I'm gonna be like if
I'm reckless then it will happen to me
because I deserve it
you know the least I could do is be you
know chill out and having a good life so
what's gonna happen after a two-month
break I think this goes for all
industries that have a break here guys
here's the thing we as Americans we take
our lifestyles for granted this is the
fact we have all these amazing
restaurants and activities and
entertainment and places to go and do
and see and you know we've gone more so
to this where we're always looking at
our phones and we're always staring at
the internet and I think what we're
going to see when this finally gets
lifted is people really really
appreciating real life and I think we're
gonna see tons of business and the
fitness industry meaning the gyms are
going to be packed because people are
gonna feel thankful that they get to
work out not that they have to work out
I think we're gonna have restaurants
because people want to see their friends
if you're like me I go to the same three
or four places and I know how's people
there and I love seeing them so I think
what we're gonna see and I think what
this is really like I'm trying to see
the good here I think the good that
we're going to see is we're going to see
people appreciate what America really is
and the lifestyles that we get to lead
that we have taken for granted for a
long time and a lot of people might
disagree with that but and I'm speaking
for myself I've taken it for granted for
a long time so I'm excited for things to
get back to normal not just for business
but for life and I think that's what
we're gonna see yep I agree and then
from a business standpoint that demand
there's gonna be tons of demand for a
lot of these businesses that have been
shut down and so you entrepreneurs you
need to be prepared for a surge if and
when we get out of this thing short term
in your companies so that's why people
need to be growing they need to be ready
because especially the fitness space
I think Andy's right gyms are gonna be
freaking packed when we get a chance to
go back packed and you need to be ready
for it and competing for those customers
yeah
I would say the same and also you should
if that's you you should be
strategically thinking right now
how am I going to come out of this with
momentum yep you know and and start
thinking and that's where the reaching
out to the customers right now or your
members who may belong to your gym or
whatever it is that you have reaching
out those people and say hey are you
okay can I do anything to help what can
we do as a company to help all these
things our investments and relationships
that will produce a return later on and
let's be honest it's great karma - I'm a
believer in karma I believe that when
you do the right thing good things
happen to you I live by that as much as
I possibly can do I make mistakes
sometimes
yeah because I'm a human but the truth
is I believe that by you just doing what
you can do for you the people that you
have right now they will take care of
you when things clear up I believe that
in my heart as real advice I don't think
it's it's not like a hypothetical thing
I think they're more important than
anything we need to come together and be
supportive of each other and even though
we're in isolation we have to share a
humanity more than ever and you guys as
young people have tools that I never had
and a generation before me never had so
I think you guys have an opportunity
right now is show people what you guys
are about because I see all the media
talked about all these the kids don't
care and they're not taking it seriously
and I just don't believe that I believe
that when you guys are informed you're
one of the most intelligent generations
ever ever seen I worked with the kids in
the children's March and I was blown
away and I think you guys care about
humanity we organized marches all around
the world on behalf of climate change
and I think you guys given the right
information can make a huge difference
and I think you care so you have to just
keep encouraging your friends to take
this seriously and to care and to do the
right thing and make sure that these
other kids who don't have food these
food banks they're getting certain you
can give anything give because right now
people are really really in need and
it's only gonna get worse and we have to
play our part and I'm saying it so I'm
gonna live it I'm gonna make sure I play
my part
I'm gonna make sure that we keep sending
trucks into neighborhoods with food
should we keep you know servicing these
food banks they had a little bit or a
large bit of the freak out last week
thank you little breakdown mini
breakdown I decided that I should help
well first of all I was like you know
what I just need to chill out I have to
I can't make one more decision today I'm
just gonna chill out I'm gonna I just
wanna look at pretty pictures of like
funny tic TOCs okay
the problem with scrolling social media
right now as a way to chill out from all
that's happening all right for every
funny cat video there's a like the
world's ending post yeah so that's a
bummer and that in case anyone is
wondering is for sure not the answer
it's not okay so then I was like this is
that this was a terrible idea you know
that like Simpsons the audio that's like
I'm in danger and so I decided I was
like I need to go watch a movie I need
to go watch something joyful from my
past I need to not focus I just right
here in this room watch movie and some
of it shows obviously the mask of zorro
zorro Antonio Banderas Antonio Banderas
doing on this Thursday
I don't know but Matt Sorum is on
Netflix and if you need that in your
life you you do you do um go ahead and
hit that up if you want more advice
wisdom guidance from other successful
entrepreneurs on how you can navigate
the coronavirus situation check out the
video right there next to me I hope you
find it valuable continue to believe and
I'll see you there will somewhat depend
on how well we all do